ernest shackleton's ship has more than
lived up to her name after 107 years at
the bottom of the ocean off antarctica
endurance has been found the right way
up largely intact rust and rot held at
bay by the freezing ocean in which she's
rested for so long
when the exhibition discovered it it was
like a miracle we could not believe the
state the stage the ship
the wood there are no wood eating
microorganisms no little animals that
feed on wood like there are elsewhere in
the world's oceans it's too cold
what damage there is to endurance was
largely caused by the ice in which she
became trapped crushing her hull and
toppling her masts and ending all hope
of reaching antarctica
endurance set sail for the continent
from south georgia on the 5th of
december 1914 she became trapped in pack
ice about six weeks later by november
the crew had to abandon the ship and she
sank below the ice the wreck has now
been found about four miles away from
the position originally recorded by the
ship's captain but more remarkable is
the escape that followed shackleton and
his men had no choice but to camp on the
ice for five months until finally
reaching elephant island in lifeboats
it's from there that shackleton and five
of his men made a 16-day journey to
south georgia to secure a rescue and the
lifeboats they modified to make that
journey and survives to this day donated
to shackleton's old school dullage
college in london
this is the tiny lifeboat from the deck
of endurance herself that shackleton
used to sail nearly 800 miles across the
southern ocean some of the most
notorious sea in the world waves as high
as these masts all the way to south
georgia it was a feat of navigation and
survival that allowed him to save all 27
members of his expedition not even
shackleton himself knew they were
actually going to survive this they had
to do it and they had to go out and try
it there was no hope for them being
rescued they were about a thousand miles
away from the next humans not only did
the expedition crew survive but more
than 100 photographic glass plates made
it back too
after the loss of endurance shackleton
had to secure his future as an explorer
shackleton knew that this was one way
he'd make the money back he also knew it
was part of the legacy if nothing
happened even before thinking of the
money he knew when we came back this
tells the story because my actual
expedition has failed these images and
the lifeboats of course were thought to
be the only major artifacts from
shackleton's heroic tale of survival to
have survived intact until today that is
tom clark sky news